menurut Kementerian kesihatan wilayah kendalian Hamas
sekurang kurangnya
100 orang terbunuh dalam serangan udara ke atas Rafa
yang padat dengan pelarian
episod serangan sengit
menyaksikan
kepulan asap memenuhi ruang udara bandar itu
yang kini
menempatkan lebih separuh jumlah penduduk Gaza
selepas mereka melarikan diri dari pengumuman
di lokasi lain di semenanjung
penjamin nathanihu
telah mengarahkan tenteranya
melancarkan serangan darat ke atas Rafa
pusat penduduk utama terakhir Gaza
yang masih belum dimasuki tentera
sejak serangan mengejut pejuang Hamas
pada 7 Oktober tahun lalu
kira kira 1.4 juta rakyat Palestin berhijrah krafah
dengan ramai yang tinggal di dalam khemah
di samping dihimpit kekurangan makanan
air dan ubat ubatan